I have an infamous picture of me in my
20s and I was just owning this look I
had a turtleneck
I had mom jeans on I was wearing a fat
goodbye think we've got the picture this
was you being serious
no oh yes I think I'm cool and are you
aware that this has now become a sort of
fancy dress outfit people do this Seth
Rogen was on the show yeah and he showed
us his version here Seth Rogen as it
actually some other people have done it
as well yeah check this out
[Applause]
this guy was like was had this look he
was like like he recognized me I was
like hello he was like you look familiar
have I shot you I was like I've never
been shot you've shot me and he was like
Nam do you model I'm a photographer do
you model and I was like no but I need
have you ever heard of headshots
I need something called headshots I was
20 years old and the guy's like I do
headshots I live like two blocks from
here no I'll give you headshots
I was like well what does it cost he's
like just cut it's fine I'll cover you I
was like oh sweet okay let's go I go to
this guy's apartment he lived on the top
floor really nice apartment of amazing
furnishings
he was like listen you probably a little
grimy probably need a shower I was like
that some really good idea shower
kinds of good soaps and great I'm
probably needed a shower and then he was
like hmm you should you should probably
wear some different clothes so he gives
me like this nice nice white shirt
there's a polo shirt a nice shirt and
and kind of like helps me and like
judges me up and stuff and we go out on
the balcony and and he takes like a
bunch of photos and he's like directing
me and telling me what to do and he
takes all these photos and takes the
film out of the camera and he puts it in
the film thing and he just gives it to
me and he was like there you go and I
just walked out and I was like yeah that
stick to that story of my hair that was
a guy who clearly couldn't afford a
haircut let alone a headshot I don't
know that I ever saw him again I if
you're watching thank you for my head
shots this is my spot you know the
spotlight it's the directory of actors
so what's weird about this is it looks
like it was a hundred years ago that I
looked like this but it wasn't that long
ago I just [__] myself up
funny hair but you look kind of the same
you know what you were slightly older
now when I went to Argos and using the
safety training video one with the boxes
[Applause]
I love Jeff on stumble no no because I
didn't have to be dead yeah where's your
corpse in Argos heavy boxes heavy boxes
we have a picture of Jamie Foxx young
yeah but now how what age are you here
[Applause]
we got the same kind of hair
bro that's a jheri curl right there I
was 18 right there that was a backdrop
to make it look like there's brick back
there no I think that's real picture now
if you thought Jamie Foxx looked old
there I think you are
[Applause]
I don't I see no problem are you about
twenty years old there yeah what's going
on in your head I wanted to look like
magnum p.i I actually grew a mustache in
high school because I played lacrosse
and I thought it would make me look more
threatening didn't really it just made
me look like a porn star I heard you
talking about Ian I'm talking about how
you were intimidated by his beauty yes I
think we've got a photograph of in as
air Coriolanus we are look at that
Wolverine eat your heart that you do
look great there Ian but check out
Patrick Stewart you've got to look
forward to
they want to be a soft very little ID
how old are you in this this looks like
someone pretending is my attempt at
Michelle Pfeiffer yeah how old are you I
think I must be ten it doesn't it looks
like a lady Gaga impersonator looks like
a girl I'm being Lady gaga for Halloween
usual up to be Lady Gaga young stars how
old are you here
Bradley shave the beard off years off me
I don't know I think it was my birthday
I think maybe three or something how
does the picture get out in the world
how do we know what my mom sends
pictures out all this we're going to
focus on the early dancing career of mr.
Ryan costing dance troupe you were in
can you tell us about cuz apparently
young dancers they could be quite
vicious
it's a cutthroat business to get out I
was on some kind of Canadian Star Search
and I somehow made it to the finals and
my main competition were these two twins
who were tap dancers and they were
dancing to phil collins 2hearts and they
had big heart-shaped bows and they were
just they were the ones to beat so I
remember you know wishing them luck and
going on stage and I was getting ready
to start was dancing the everybody dance
now by C&C Music Factory of course
getting ready to start which is this is
how you started a winning dance number
if you wanna go into the just off stage
and the two twins are standing there
it's like the twins from the shining and
they're just going like this
[Laughter]
like that Means War why I just shimmied
my way all the way to it to that trophy
to that tiny little trophy all it's a
tall girl true but obviously it's not
you're in it in it yeah that was the was
that the that was the point that was the
gimmick they let me dance there for free
because I was a guy because if you had a
guy you you would win oh okay yeah so
are you are you ready to see the I
believe you're dancing to Kathy Dennis's
classic touch me
did the troupe of a name right it was
elite dance studio old enough to know
better
enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
I wish I could say someone said here you
have to wear this that was my idea I
thought I have a vision for this number
and silverhammer pants the silverhammer
Prancer we gave them enough of a shot we
gave up with hammer but I don't I think
we should should have kept them going
you know yeah
[Music]
you